sixty years ago birth was attacked we
won the war they destroy the planet
everyone's been evacuated nothing human
remains we're here for drum repair 166
back online with a mop-up crew
we had a really good experience working
at IMAX on on Tron so from the beginning
we knew we wanted this to plan IMAX
screens we are an effective team this is
Jack Harper I love this scope that it
provides I love the sound our loss it's
why I go to the movies it's an
experience I do my weights check and we
can finally leave and join the others
the two words that I had from the very
beginning project was a beautiful
desolation blue skies black sand a very
kind of monochromatic palette it has a
haunting beauty to it I mean when you're
looking at the world that is 60 years
from now and has been obliterated
it was important to me and to Tom for us
as a viewer to be able to see everything
that Jack sees I've been watching you
jack bill I do it's time to learn the
truth I'm ecstacy perfect format for
that this film is formatted for IMAX it
is made for IMAX when you have that kind
of depth that kind of scope that kind of
scale just feels that much more
immersive it really fills your vision
and it provides a level of sharpness and
detail not only in actors you can see
the glint in their eyes but also in
landscapes for a standard release
everything will be in the widescreen
aspect ratio and that's kind of what I
composed for but I always protected for
the full frame which is a taller aspect
ratio for IMAX we have an unidentified
object invite survivors yeah human the
drones will handle this come on wants
you to stand down
negative tower yeah this is
insubordinate behavior
it's just an epic story something you've
never seen reformed you need to know who
are you
dusty bring back old memories things you
need to know I don't want I'm still an
identity calm protect you
and this the audience is gonna have a
special experience
I can't wait see the movie at IMAX
earth still my home
you